T
HERE WITH DR. OZ AND DAVE
McCORMICK SO THE PRESIDENT'S
ENDORSEMENT MATTERS IN CERTAIN
INSTANCES.
>> I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING
DAVID PURDUE SAID TODAY ABOUT AN
EVENT ABOUT STACY ABRAMS,
OBVIOUSLY THE PRESUMPTIVE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE IN GEORGIA.
>> YOU HEAR WHAT STACY SAID THIS
WEEKEND?
GEORGIA IS THE WORST PLACE IN
THE COUNTRY TO LIVE.
HEY, SHE AIN'T FROM HERE, LET
HER GO BACK TO WHERE SHE CAME
FROM.
ONLY THING SHE WANTS IS TO BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
SHE DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE
OF GEORGIA.
THAT'S CLEAR.
WHEN SHE TOLD BLACK FARMERS YOU
DON'T NEED TO BE ON THE FARM AND
TOLD BLACK WORKERS IN
HOSPITALITY AND ALL THIS, YOU
DON'T, SHE IS DEMEANING HER OWN
RACE WHEN IT COMES TO THAT, I AM
REALLY OVER THIS.
SHE SHOULD NEVER BE CONSIDERED
GOVERNOR MATERIAL FOR ANY STATE
MUCH LESS OUR STATE WHERE SHE
HATES TO LIVE.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION.
>> A, IT'S DISGUSTING AND HE'S
DEMEANING THE HUMAN RACE TALKING
THAT WAY, FIRST OF ALL HE'S
LYING, SHE NEVER TOLD BLACK
FARMERS OTHER THING, SAID THERE
SHOULD BE JOBS OTHER THAN
HOSPITALITY AND AGRICULTURE IN
GEORGIA, BUT SHE DIDN'T MAKE IT
RACIAL, HE MADE IT RACIAL AND
FOR HIM TO SAY SHE SHOULD GO
BACK WHERE SHE CAME FROM, YOU
KNOW, SHE SPENT MOST HER LIFE IN
GEORGIA.
THIS IS THE KIND OF STUFF, YOU
KNOW, HE'S FAILING, LOSING, AND
LOSING FOR A REASON.
HE JUMPED IN BASED ON A LIE AND
STILL LYING.
>> MAGGIE, IN TERMS OF THE
PURDUE RACE, DO YOU KNOW HOW THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IS FEELING OR
VIEWING THIS PRIVATELY?
IS HE GOING TO CHANGE
ENDORSEMENT STRATEGY GOING
FORWARD?
>> THERE IS SOME TALK ABOUT THE
IDEA HE IS GOING TO LAY OFF
JUMPING INTO A LOT OF THESE
RACES, I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE SOMETHING LIKE THIS
BUT THIS WAS A PRETTY UNIQUE
SITUATION BECAUSE OF HOW TRUMP
FEELS ABOUT KEMP, HE'S NOT
HAPPY, ULTIMATELY BLAMING PURDUE
THEN TELLING PEOPLE THIS RACE IS
STILL WINNABLE UNLESS YOU'RE
UNABLE TO READ POLLS, IT'S
CLEARLY NOT WINNABLE FOR PURDUE.
IT'S NOT LIKELY TO FORCE A
RUN-OFF AND IT IS A REFLECTION
ON TRUMP NO MATTER WHAT HE SAYS,
I WAS STRUCK BY THE NUMBER YOU
READ IN THAT STATEMENT ABOUT
82-3 IS HIS ENDORSEMENT RECORD,
THAT'S NOT HIS ENDORSEMENT
RECORD, I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
NUMBER IS SUPPOSED TO BE BUT A
NUMBER OF OTHER RACES HE
ENDORSED AND CANDIDATE LOST
STARTING LAST YEAR AND THEY KEEP
TRYING TO REWRIELT THE NUMBER.
>> TRUMP HAS THIS HUGE WAD OF
MONEY HE RASZED THROUGH
DONATIONS.
HAS HE BEEN SPENDING THAT FOR
THESE CANDIDATES?
>> ALMOST ON -- EXCEPT FOR
PURDUE, COWORKER REPORTED THIS
WEEK I THINK IT WAS 2 MILLION
OVERALL TO PURDUE, THAT WAS A
RARITY.
IN GENERAL THE COMPLAINT HAS
BEEN TRUMP IS HOARDING THE MONEY
AND NOT DOING A LOT TO HELP
OTHER REPUBLICANS.
>> SO DAVID URBAN, IS IT WISE,
IF YOU'RE A TRUMP SUPPORTER, IS
IT WISE FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TO BE GETTING INVOLVED IN THESE
RACES?
TO BE ENDORSING OR SHOULD BE
MORE SELECTIVE?
>> NO, NO HE, IF THE PRESIDENT,
IF HE WOULD LISTEN TO ME OR
ANYBODY, HE WOULD HUSBAND THOSE
ENDORSEMENTS RIGHT, AND NOT
REALLY HAND THEM OUT AS FREELY
AS HE DOES.
THEY -- LISTEN, ENDORSEMENTS
REALLY MATTER IN THESE CLOSE
RACES LIKE YOU SAW IN OHIO AND
IN SOME CONGRESSIONAL RACES,
THEY REALLY CAN SWING A DISTRICT
PRETTY EASILY.
SOME RACES, YOU KNOW, THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD JUST SIT OUT
LIKE IN PENNSYLVANIA, I THINK
THE PRESIDENT INJURED HIS BRAND
IN PENNSYLVANIA BY GOING IN
MAKING ENDORSEMENT, MADE A LOT
OF PEOPLE UNHAPPY IN THE SENATE
RACE, A LOT UNHAPPY IN THE
GOCHB
GOVERNOR'S RACE, FOR WHAT, YOU
GET MAYBE ONE PERSON WITH DR. OZ
IF HE DOES GET ELECTED, ONLY
NEED 70% OF THE REPUBLICAN BASE
IN THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA SO
AT WHAT COST?
I DON'T THINK THE JUICE IS WORTH
THE SQUEEZE ON IT SOME OF THESE.
>> DAVID, IF PURDUE LOSES, DO
YOU THINK THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WOULD SAY THE RACE WAS RIGGED?
>> I DON'T THINK HE'LL SAY THE
RACE WAS RIGGED, HE'LL SAY DAVID
PURDUE RAN A BAD RACE.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RESOURCES, ANDERSON, I THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAS $180 MILLION I
THINK IN THE SUPER PAC,
SOMEWHERE IN THAT NUMBER, MAGGIE
PROBABLY KNOWS BETTER BUT
$2 MILLION GETS AH WEEK OF TV IN
GEORGIA, IT'S AN EXPENSIVE MEDIA
MARKET SO IF HE WAS ALL